[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Stanford
Graduate School of Business online
information session my name is Stephanie
whittlin and I'm a member of the MBA
admissions office I'm excited to spend
the next 60 minutes with you talking
about the MBA experience the admissions
process and answering your questions
you'll also have a chance to meet a
couple of our current students and ask
them about their experience here on
campus so let's begin let's start by
having each of you briefly introduce
yourselves
and talk a little bit about your
backgrounds what were you doing before
business school and what your goals are
after you graduate I'll start with you
an image thanks Tiffany my name is anna
mae sugar wall i'm a second year student
at the GSB I grew up in Palma de Pradesh
where I spent the first 18 years of my
life
I did my undergrad from IIT Delhi and
post-graduation I've worked with a
management consulting firm in New Delhi
for about one and a half years and then
spent about two and a half years in
Mumbai working for a private equity
forum post graduation I plan to be
investing broadly
I'm sorry Mita I'm from Hyderabad again
spent the first 18 years of my life in
Hyderabad then went to IIT Madras for
engineering after iit I joined Unilever
and Mumbai as a management trainee I
worked there for about three and a half
years when I got into GSB my goal of my
my goal for before getting into GSB was
to actually transition from consumer
goods background to consumer tech
product management so before joining GSB
I did a couple of internships in this
space okay great thank you both now
let's answer some questions from our
audience
the first question we'll start with is
what's the best way to prepare to get
the most out of Stanford if I'm
fortunate enough to be admitted okay I
can take that one
I think GSB is a place where you can
virtually do everything but what I
realized spending time here is you can
do everything here but not at the same
time so what I would encourage all of
you to think through is what are the two
three main things you learn to achieve
at the Business School and keep that top
of mind and as you evaluate the
opportunities at a GSB keeping that lens
in mind so that like when you walk out
of GSB a ton of two years you don't feel
like you have not achieved what you came
in thinking about totally agree with
what animage said in addition to that I
kind of work til the end of July I
barely took any break don't make that
mistake I would say take a couple of
months off and spend time with your
loved ones because you are not gonna see
them very often once you come here so
that's my advice great thank you both
the next question when is the best time
to apply in your career trajectory and
I'll take this one from an admissions
perspective you can add any color if
you'd like so if you think about it from
an admissions perspective when you apply
is completely irrelevant
we admit candidates who are just
graduating from college so we admit
individuals who are college seniors and
we also have individuals who have at
least a decade or two of work experience
in every class every year so it can run
the whole gamut in terms of work
experience I think it's important for
you to think about what makes sense for
you so when is the right time for you
rather than how we will evaluate the
number of years of work experience you
have do you guys have anything to add
there okay very good
the next question what is the biggest
surprise you experienced as you began
your Stanford MBA journey um I can take
that I think the biggest surprise for me
was the feedback culture that existed
here especially the certain courses
which we do in the query very first
quarto it gives us a good taste into how
much feedback is valued and how much
people are eager to act upon the
feedback they get it was something very
new to me and the second thing which was
surprising to me is the sheer number of
events that were there for people with
all kinds of preferences for socializing
there's no one way to do the GSB
experience there is so much support and
resources provided to help everybody
realize their GSB social life the way
they want it to be that was a pleasant
surprise I would say yeah yeah I think
in terms of academic experience the
class environment here encourages and
appreciates active participation from
all students so I think coming from a
background where in the classroom
environment you're not used to sharing
those many experiences or views it's it
was important to appreciate that it's
the culture that wants you to share your
views and experiences in the class are
there specific admissions requirements
for international students I'll add my
take to this and that is explicitly know
one of the requirements that we do ask
of international candidates if you have
attended a university where the primary
language of instruction was not in
English we do require the TOEFL we
evaluate all candidates based on the
same three criteria as I discussed in
the video intellectual vitality
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions so
all candidates are evaluated equally the
next question what is life like at the
GSB as an international student I think
GSB is an environment where you have a
lot of diversity in as many aspects as
you can think of
as an international students like I'm in
a class with international students from
more than 60 countries and I think
everybody comes up with their own
background own way in which they grew up
and it's I found it personally very
fascinating to just appreciate the fact
that how different people here look at
life or like half what motivates them
personally
and I think for some of us who have not
grown up in a culture with a lot of
diversity it's really good to appreciate
how people think about different things
both in personal life and academically
and those of the international students
I've really appreciated the American way
of looking at both academic and
non-academic things and how what
students from other countries bring to
the table I think I'm really impressed
by the kind of resources that exist for
international students I'm an
international student who has never
lived in US before I've lived all my
life in India before moving here but I
found so much support all around me
because there was like I mentioned in my
or in my previous on so there are so
many resources available to socialize
the way you want to socialize mingle
with other like-minded people I
currently work in the Students
Association International Committee we
put in a lot of thought to actually
incorporate all the major international
events in Stanford life we recently both
of us together organized a valley party
which was a big head it was attended by
like almost all of our other
nationalities nationalities as well
similarly there are so there's so much
happening with different identity clubs
that are there at GSB built a Latin
American Student Association image on
image heads there are there's an Africa
Business Club there is Hispanic students
Business Association so there are so
many places where you you get a lot of
support career-wise as well as socially
so that's a great thing at GSB for an
international student according to me
okay great thank you
the next question I'll address as well
which is how do I craft a good essay
it's a popular question what I will say
as you think about writing your essay
it's important that you use your
authentic voice first and foremost what
we're trying to identify when we read
your essay is not only what matters most
to you but explicitly why we want to
understand your core values we want to
hear from your perspective your inner
voice what's important to you and I
would say that it's not necessarily a
crafting of your essay as much as it is
being authentic and true to yourself and
being able to convey that in a clear
manner in the essay guys have anything
to add I think I would just like to
reiterate it's not a place to just show
your strengths and I would encourage all
of you to be authentic one dribble and
these are some things that the GSB
community sort of prides itself in so
it's a good way to show that through
your essays that it's not an individual
exercise I think it's a team effort
I personally rather on my essay by like
my closest friends and colleagues and
family some of them so it was it's
really useful to take inputs of people
who know you very well
yes yeah we often will say it is helpful
to get perspective from those who know
you incredibly well and when they read
your essay that it sounds like you and
only you yeah yeah the next question is
how do you finance your MBA was it is it
in portable for the average Indian
person and then I'll address some of the
questions regarding financial aid and
scholarships so I personally used a mix
of three different sources in small part
of it was my own personal savings from
with the job I did before business
school the second major part was the
financial aid that I received from the
school and the third part was the
student loan that is available to all
students
that apply to the GSP so I think these
were the three sources that helped me
finance my MBA and to the question of it
being affordable I come from a
middle-class family and I think these
three sources combine like put you in a
very comfortable a position to do this
MBA in my case I am a recipient off
reliance the yoruba Ambani Fellowship
which covered a majority of my expenses
apart from that I also used some of my
savings from before GSB as well as some
family support yeah yes we do offer a
reliance Dharavi fellowship for Indian
citizens who can benefit from two years
of nearly full-time tuition so that
scholarship that fellowship is available
to all candidates who are citizens of
India did you consider any graduate
programs in India and why did you decide
to come to the u.s. for your MBA
I actually was did not consider other
MBA programs in India I really liked the
job at Asheville which I got through an
internship that I did it in my show do
while I was in college I wanted to walk
before I do my MBA and I was
particularly fascinated by an by an MBA
in u.s. when I saw some of my seniors in
college that I really looked up to go
that way and hearing from their
experiences about doing an MBA from a
school like Stanford I understood that
the global perspective and the kind of
diverse experience we get in you know
MBA school it in US and that too having
worked for a couple of years before
doing an MBA is really valuable and it's
very different from doing an MBA in
India I have a lot of friends who have
done MBA in India and they all have like
they have a great they have great
careers I have nothing against it but I
just feel like a u.s. MBA is pretty
diverse and it's a great life experience
I think in addition to global
perspective I think I would also
encourage all of you to think of the
cohort the cohort here as I said comes
from like more than 60 different
countries have varying level of our work
experience and I think that sort of
diversity is very difficult to replicate
in an Indian graduate school so I think
that is one factor that's real for me ok
moving along we'll go to the next
question can you talk about some of your
favorite classes you probably have one
to share about professors so I am just
rushing drama touchy-feely class I've
just concluded my touchy-feely course
this quarter which was Oh
life-changing experience at the cost of
sounding cliched but it's it's
undoubtedly the best experience at GSB
so far secondly there are a lot of other
great classes in I'm particularly
interested in technology so I do a lot
of courses in technology and
entrepreneurship so there is a great
course called electronic business which
happened which is in the first year then
there's another great course of building
and managing sales organization which is
a very practical course and you get to
listen to some of the some of some
prominent sales leaders in the industry
there are several other courses for
people into interested in
entrepreneurship like startup garage
where you can start from the scratch
from idea phase to execution phase a lot
of people who are into entrepreneurship
probably like the class yeah I think for
me are the classes which are related to
communication or merging difficult
conversations have stood out and one
class that comes to mind is managing
growing enterprises by Joel Peterson who
is the chairman of JetBlue and that
class basically talks about how do you
have difficult conversations with the
board how do you fire someone how do you
give feedback to employers not being
performing well so some of these
conversations are we were faced at all
phases of our life and was just
practicing them in our risk free
environment some
valued a lot yeah yeah I find oftentimes
I talked to students also about our
prospective candidates about leadership
labs which addresses a lot of those same
questions what do you do if you have to
fire some how do you handle difficult
conversations so you'll get lots of
practice on that the next question is
what percent of your coursework is
theory versus hands-on learning do you
guys want to share a little bit about
what your perspective has been or
experience in the classroom as far as
that goes I think it'll be hard to put a
percentage value to it but I would say
like most of the learning here is
experiential and sort of working in
groups or teams to basically work that
true for example like even in the first
quarter if we start with something
called lead labs in which you have a
cohort of six students who basically
give feedback to each other every week
on what about you encourages me to
follow you it's a very simple question
but just the fact that you hear how your
actions land on different people in a
small cohort week after week just sort
of the good lab to put yourself through
I think some of these activities where
you are either interacting with
different people or like doing it on
hands-on on a software or on a lab just
makes the learning process much more
interactive and much more fun so I would
say like most of my learning has been
exponential or working in teams or
having said that like some of the
courses which require a theoretical work
like accounting and stuff would be there
and I think that's the best way to learn
some of those courses yeah yeah so it's
a mix of both there is a good there's a
good number of courses which are heavily
theoretical and there's all there's an
equal number of courses which which are
experienced all and practical in nature
risk of sounding repetitive touchy-feely
is like very practical there is no
little to no Theory involved in it and
similarly start garages like one hour
for class every day but like four to
five hours of practical work outside of
class every week there are a lot of
design school courses which are very
popular amongst the GSB students which
are all hands-on yes there are a few
courses which involve fieldwork
there are definitely global global
experience programs which account this
coursework but it is like basically
going to a different country with a
bunch of your classmates so it's so it's
an interesting mix of both I would say
the next question we'll take is what
clubs and activities outside of class
are you enrolled in you have kind of to
me I am really passionate about ensuring
international students get all the
required resources to pursue the careers
that they want to pursue and I like I
mentioned I also came to GSB you with a
goal of transition into tech product
management so I'm I got involved in tech
club where you're on the clock yeah I
Senate where a lot of discussions and
decisions are made so I I would say all
these experiences have have enriched my
GSB life so far and you can keep busy
for sure yeah for me it's very similar I
co-chaired academic committee here and
also sit on the Senate of the Student
Association with Sue shmitah
I am deeply interested in businesses in
India and I'm the president for the
business in India Club here and in
addition I'm also involved in our
committee called future of my education
in which we are holistically looking at
what are the different ways in which we
can basically cater to the MBA program
here and make it even more attractive
for students going forward okay great
the next question how has your proximity
to Silicon Valley benefit you compared
to other programs not
the area I think the biggest benefit for
me is the proximity or to all the
protagonists of the cases that we do in
the classes mm-hmm
all the club all the classes which cover
technology and entrepreneurship have
cases surrounding real life to talk in
their protagonists who live like right
outside Stanford like in Palo Alto and
Mountain View so it's very easy to have
access to people like that so every
single day in each of my classes I have
one of these people who have like taken
a company public or have like achieved
several other great things in technology
space venture capitalist venture
capitalist come and talk to us which is
something I can't imagine happening
secondly I can totally see how it
benefits us and in the way of networking
as well it's so easy for us to like call
anybody up and ask them to come and do a
bbl which is a brown-bag lunch
lunchtime session where they come and
talk about topic of their interest or
like just represent a company that wants
to hire from GSB so I think these are
the two benefits which I can very
obviously see how yeah and just in terms
of like access to protagonists around
the cases it's also proximity to the
culture of Silicon Valley I think this
is a culture which sort of celebrates
taking risk being entrepreneurial going
after what seems impossible and just
being in that environment sort of
especially for risk-averse people like
me sort of encourages you to go think
outside the box
go achieve your dream and so I think
it's just a good no mental laughs to put
yourself through great all right and
what was the application and admissions
process like from your perspective as a
student I think for me the application
process was you know a great mental
journey to go through because the
application process sort of encouraged
me to think deeply about what matters to
me and what defines me as a
and I think this is the culture which is
like vastly celebrated at the GSB of
knowing yourself well and the
application process sort of encourages
each one of us to sort of go through
that mental journey and it was also
interesting to like get a chance to
interview with an Illumina which now and
like share their experiences what they
valued at the GSB so I think it's a good
mix of getting to know yourself getting
to know GSB from different diverse
perspectives so it was a good reflection
of the GSB culture change gender yeah we
talked about the journey here at the GSB
but it really starts in the application
yes yeah do you have anything you want
to add to that yeah I mean I strongly
agree with what Anna Mae said about it
being a mental journey it's a deep
personal experience I don't think any
other schools application essay would
probe you to think as much about your
self as much as what Stanford I see this
woman when I started writing my response
to what matters the most you and why it
it really prompted me to think about my
entire life and pick out instances that
really mattered to me
and that journey really extended when I
came to GSB like I gave a talk it was
like an extension of that yes yeah so
it's really interesting how the journey
which starts it what matters the most to
you and why keeps getting employee
iterated and improved upon through
several other experiences yeah a deeply
introspective process that continues
even here how did you select the person
who wrote your recommendation letter I
think it was kind of obvious for me
because I selected my immediate manager
and his manager the two people who had
the best view to my work because that
was my first job I haven't really spent
time in any other company I worked at
Unilever for like me I joined Unilever
right out of college and spent all my
time there and my first boss knew saw me
go through like being a first-time
manager to like to finishing to
finishing off a stint
do us properly so
he was the best person position to like
write about me and similarly his manager
also had a good view to what happened
through my career at Unilever so these
are the two people who yeah I'll go to
you two but I want to add to what you
said which another question is who
should applicants choose and I think
it's important that as you are
considering individuals that you do look
to those who know you most well right so
those who have had the closest
experience and can speak specifically to
things that you have done what you've
accomplished and so it's more important
that you find someone who who knows you
well and can can write on that behalf I
think you covered it mostly I would just
encourage you to like take the
recommendations to someone who knows you
well and can talk specific examples
because that is something that the
admission office sort of appreciates
like some tangible examples of the
qualities they are highlighting in the
recommendation letter yeah and we do
have requirements of course that you
would want to select your immediate
direct current supervisor unless there
is a reason that you are unable to do so
what is student life like at the GSB and
is it easy to blend in
I think GSB people are some of the
easiest people to blend in with because
everybody comes in because we all care
deeply about introspection and
self-awareness people are very grounded
really care about knowing where you
really come from instead of just the
superficial details of your
opportunities to meet a lot of
interesting people at home yeah I think
very similar I think this is the culture
that sort of celebrates the differences
and sort of encourages you to be
yourself and I think one common phrase
that we use here is fitting in and stand
out and I think both are equally
celebrated here there are a lot of
things that we share the class and in
that sense we fit in but we also
celebrates dining out because each one
of us bring a different thing or to the
class and that is something that we as a
community appreciate want to develop
further so it's not a pressure to just
fit in but also stand out in your own
unique way yeah great what should one
focus on when they start attending
Stanford so preparation wise so to speak
how do you decide what classes and
experiences to take advantage of so I
can start on this one
ah it's sort of goes back to the point
that it's really important that you have
two or three broad goals for yourself
when you come to stand for it when you
come here there were literally millions
of opportunities and you would want to
be a part of dance show you would want
to be part of this club and this student
activity for me in the first week when I
came to Stanford I made a list of like
these are the three things I want to
walk away from out of Stanford and every
activity I sort of try to do here I use
this lens to evaluate whether it makes
sense for me personally and it is just
good to keep a center and be honest to
yourself so that when you are done with
the two years you feel proud of what you
have done yeah yeah I hear people say
it's like drinking out of a water hose
there's so many options and
opportunities to get involved it is
helpful to sort of have a little bit of
a an idea or focus but also be open to
other options um have you taken any
classes outside of the GSB I did I did a
couple and here I did a couple of
classes and the computer science
department mm-hmm
and I also did a really extensive Design
School class both were very unique
experiences
nothing like GSB a lot of fun or getting
to know people outside of GSB out
it's called across the street classes
and it's a great way to get
the GSB Babu especially in the first
year where you live in a dorm right
across your classroom complex so it's
it's one way to like really get out
there and meet other interesting people
in the product Stanford community I
think taking classes outside GSB is like
a very unique value proposition that
Stanford has just the proximity in
relationship GSB shares with other other
schools within the Stanford family it
just gives you a lot of different
perspectives and helps you and basically
expand your network beyond GSB I took a
really interesting class public speaking
across the street which was very unique
and very different from the classes we
do at the GSB so it's a it's a great
resource that is available to GSB
students yeah and they're talking about
across the street which of course is our
term that we use for really any of the
other leading professional graduate
schools on campus that you'll have
access to you can literally walk within
10 or 15 minutes and be at some of these
other professional schools on campus and
it is why over 90 percent of our
students will take a course across the
street so it's a big part of your
experience what is the professional
background of your peers at the GSB are
they diverse in industry and experience
I think we touched a little bit on the
importance of diversity within the class
but anything to elaborate on yeah I
think in terms of professional diversity
this is as wide as it gets there are
people from consulting private equity to
military to operations I have one of my
classmates who was a NASCAR race driver
so it's like diversity in terms of as
broad as it gets and the way it sort of
shows up and is helpful in classroom is
like your professional background shapes
the way you look at different business
problems or non business problems and
just having that diversity encourages
you to think in many different ways to a
problem which you wouldn't have thought
of otherwise so I think it's as diverse
as it can theoretically get yeah totally
agree with that and not to mention the
number of Olympians which we have
I think these this diversity is really
helpful in helping you with your own
career pursuits I think because there
are if you want to make a switch from
one industry to a different industry
there are already a few people who have
done that before coming to GSB so they
can you can just grab a coffee with them
and understand what that industry is all
about or what that particular function
is all about yeah and get some key
contacts which will help you make
inroads in that into that and people are
so willing to help you all the time
mm-hmm there everybody is just a phone
call or text message away so this
diversity can really be leveraged to
follow your passions great thank you
um when is the right time to apply to
this GSB and which round is best so I
talked a little bit about the right time
to apply is when you are ready
that could mean right when you graduate
from college it could mean that you want
two three five ten years of work
experience from our perspective and in
the admissions office when you decide to
apply is not necessarily important to us
but it's important for us to understand
why it is now one of the other questions
was about which round is best in general
it is preferred to apply in round one or
round two there are certain
opportunities that we provide as a
result if you are around one around two
applicant we offer admin weekend so you
have the opportunity to come here on
campus if at all possible there are
other access access that you'll have
available to you but we certainly want
you to apply when you're ready so if
that means waiting until round three
that's fine as well not sure if you guys
have any perspective having gone through
the application yourself the process I
think you go in well and I would
encourage you to not worry too much
about round one versus round two round
three is something that as I said should
only be used in extraordinary
circumstances but between round one and
round two I would not put
lot of maths behind it whenever you are
ready a new thing is the best time that
long suits best for you okay all right
what is the reliance fellowship and what
are the requirements so I touched on
this a little bit which is that we do
offer a fellowship for those individuals
who live in India and have a desire to
return to India after graduating there
are specific requirements you can go
online to our website and learn more
about that under our fellowship
opportunities do you have any classmates
so you have been two knowers of course I
do you want to speak to for sure so the
process to apply for this fellowship is
to actually it begins before any of the
GSB applications process starts it
starts with an essay that you have to
write about what are your aspirations
for India how do you want to see India
shape up in the near future based on bad
AC on your resume or you will be
shortlisted of a bunch of 50 students
and there is a networking session which
is organized towards the end of August I
think where you'll meet with several
Stanford admissions staff as well as
based in India there's there are a
couple of group activities and a lot of
interaction with the Stanford alumni and
fellow applicants and once you do that
the you apply along with everybody else
in round one or round to depend in when
I applied to it I could only apply in
round one but it has been flexed last
year and now you can apply either in
round one around to normal application
process there's nothing different about
the Stanford application process oh the
only additional step as the essay which
you have to submit around July mid-july
and the networking sessions that I just
talked about and these 50 finalists will
apply like any other standard regular
stand block weekend any the round one
around oh yeah and Sue Smith is talking
about the pre application process which
yes is what you would do in this summer
early summer and then we also offer a
reliance finalist day where we bring in
everyone
to learn a little bit more about the MBA
program and the GSB experience and give
you the opportunity to meet alumni of
the program as well and then the second
part of the process is for you to apply
just like any other candidate through
the general MBA application process and
would evaluate you as such yes what
career networking and other professional
opportunities have you been able to take
advantage of while at the GSB so I think
in terms of career opportunities this is
ocean of opportunities
I know classmates who have been like
trying to switch either industries
geographies or function and I think that
opportunity is available through various
different resources one is the career
management services as the CMC as we
call it here and they organize the globe
workshops special workshops for
international students on how does
American style of interviewing happens
they have company networking nights
where companies from all sorts of
different industries come and you can
interact with them and they also have
on-campus recruitment process in terms
of networking it goes beyond just the
CMC and Sushma tell you that too there
are brown bag lunches and what we call
BBS hosted by different companies all
throughout the year and that's a good
way to one appreciate what these
companies do and also get to know the
professionals they are be in touch with
them learn from them over there and not
just during the recruitment season and
in terms of professional opportunities
like there are a lot of activities that
go on like right from interviewing
skills to like building your resume to
actually figuring out how you what
career is best for you so like I
remember like some of the workshops in
the beginning of the year which was
super helpful in terms of just thinking
through what sort of career would help
you find the most meaning in your life
yeah so I think it's a really vast ocean
of opportunities and it ranges from very
philosophically very tactical approach
so +12 everything he said apart from
that a little bit of detail about how
happens you know so there are two ways
like animation alluded to one is though
on campus recruitment way which kind of
gets over by January and mid-february
traditional kind of companies that come
on campus then there's network
networking based job search which
happens like later in the winter quarter
and in through your spring quarter one
unique thing about stanford is that a
lot of people especially for internships
really want to pursue new things so they
tend to prefer network based job search
and what exactly helps network based job
search there are two different avenues
wreckin think of one is the clubs a lot
of these companies approach clubs and
the clubs conduct the BBS that an image
was talking about that's a great way to
network and apply to these companies and
then CMC also has a lot of alumni
information you just need to like figure
out what companies you're interested in
there are career advisors that will help
you figure out how to approach the
company and who are the right people
that you need to contact in those
companies and the third sometimes used
resources professors I would say a lot
of professors are like track nation's in
industry they all either operate
companies currently or they have
operated companies in the past so they
are also they're very well-connected in
the industry so in first year slightly
difficult to get access to those
professors because a lot of them teach
in the second year but still it can be
done because nobody is gonna deny
helping you if you reach out to them you
just need to know who to reach out to so
professors are kind slightly underrated
but very useful resource I want to touch
a little bit on there are of course a
lot of resources as you mentioned and
also there is the AAP the academic
adjustment period begins in your first
quarter so how did that affect your or
tell us a little bit about that
experience sort of at that time that you
can not have to worry so much about the
career trajectory
sure so academic adjustment period is
the first six weeks when you get in the
GSB and I think it's a really important
period because like when you come in
here most of you would be moving to the
u.s. most likely for the first time you
will be living in the u.s. we'll be
meeting a set of new friends new
classmates getting to settle in a new
educational environment so this
basically six weeks provide a buffer
where you are not exposed to any career
activities or any club activities and
you can just focus on a focus on
settling into the system get to know
your classmates well spend some time
socially and things like that so I think
for me personally ap was a great time to
just make myself comfortable in the
system before the floodgates open and
you start recruiting or joining their
clubs all right well we're coming to the
close of our webinar but before we go do
either of you have any final words of
advice I'll start with you switch me
back I think when I applied to GSB I had
a very one-dimensional approach to it
like I want to switch my careers but I
think a GSB experiences a lot more than
that it's a lot of it's a lot about
knowing yourself better and becoming a
better person and I'm I'm not just
throwing some corny lines out there it's
really true there are so many
experiences like talk touchy-feely and
just the community around you which
really helps you understand yourself and
be a better version of yourself and I am
really having a lot of fun I don't think
I would do it all over again if I have
to thank you so for me it's a very
similar a one realization I hide here is
basically technical skills and our
ethical skills are simply hygiene as you
think of leadership roles and
interpersonal skills and how you lead
teams is basically what differentiates
you as you grow up the corporate ladder
and I think GSB just provides you that
lab where you can experiment with
different styles of your
leadership or how you interact with
people and I think that journey is such
an invaluable resource that you would be
thankful for it for the rest of your
life great great great advice both of
you thank you um thank you both for
joining us and thanks to all of you out
there who are participating you can
learn more about the Stanford MBA
program on our website and by watching
our videos on YouTube
[Music]
you